thank you for that find me the Miller in
Johannesburg let's go back to the summit
to hear from the Indian Prime Minister
Narendra Modi
ladies and gentlemen
congratulations
and thanks once again to my dear friend
president
for the wonderful arrangements made for
the organization of the 15th brick
Summit and for his Hospitality it is a
great pleasure for me
foreign
[Music]
we have had
many achievements during this journey
a new development bank
is playing an important role in the
development of the countries of the
global South
through its contingency reserve
arrangement we have created a financial
safety net
through initiatives such as the brick
satellite constellation the vaccine r d
Center
Mutual recognition of Pharma products we
are bringing about
a positive changes in the lives of
ordinary citizens in brics countries
through initiatives such as the youth
Summit brics games the think tanks
Council we are
strengthening People to People ties
between all countries
in order to give the brics agenda New
Direction India has given some
suggestions such as the railway research
Network
uh the online bricks database close
cooperation between msmes and a startup
Forum I am pleased that significant
progress has been made in all these
areas excellencies
in order to further expand our close
cooperation I would like to place before
you a few suggestions the first is
cooperation in the area of space
we have already been working on a brick
satellite constellation taking a step
forward we can think about creating a
brick space exploration Consortium
under this
we can work on areas such as space
research and weather monitoring for
Global good
my second suggestion is a cooperation in
the areas of Education skill development
and Technology
in order to make bricks a future ready
organization we must make our societies
Future Ready
technology can play an important role in
this regard
in order to provide access
to education for children living in
remote and rural areas in India we have
created the deeksha platform that is
digital infrastructure for knowledge
sharing at the same time in order to
promote Innovation among school children
we have created 10 000 utter tinkering
Labs across the country in order to
remove language barriers and AI based
language platform
is being used
the coven platform has been made to
manage vaccinations
through our digital public
infrastructure that is the India stack
Public Service delivery is being
revolutionized
diversity is one of India's greatest
trends
the solution to any problem found in
India has withstood the test of this
diversity and therefore these Solutions
can easily be implemented in any part of
the world in this regard we will be
pleased to share with brics Partners all
these platforms developed in India
my third suggestion is that in order to
identify each other's strengths we can
carry out together a skills mapping
exercise through this we can complement
each other in the development Journey
my fourth suggestion
relates to big cats
in all five brics countries various
species of big cats can be found in
large numbers
and the international big cat Alliance
we can make joint efforts for their
protection
my fifth suggestion relates to
traditional medicine all our countries
have traditional medicine ecosystems can
we together create a repository of
traditional medicine excellencies
under South Africa's presidency
countries of the global South have been
given special importance in brics we
heartily welcome this
this is not just an expectation of the
present times but a necessity as well
under its G20 presidency India has given
this subject the highest priority based
on our core value one Earth one family
one future we are making efforts to move
forward together with all countries
in the voice of global South Summit
organized in January earlier this year
125 countries participated and shared
their concerns and priorities
we have also proposed permanent
membership for the African Union in the
G20
I am confident that all brick partners
are also together in the G20 and that
all will support our proposal
giving a special place to all these
efforts within bricks as well will
further boost the morale of countries of
the global South excellencies India
fully supports the expansion of brics
membership
and we welcome moving forward on this
based on consensus in 2016 during
India's presidency we had defined bricks
as a group building responsive inclusive
and Collective Solutions
seven years later we can say that bricks
will be breaking barriers
revitalizing economies
inspiring Innovation creating
creating opportunities and shaping the
future
together with all brics Partners we will
continue to contribute actively to make
this new definition meaningful thank you
and we have been listening